Pokemon detective Pikachu stars Ryan
Reynolds as the voice of Pikachu and
justice Smith as the son of a detective
that's recently gone missing in rhyme
city and Tim played by Smith goes to
rhyme city to search for his missing
father with the help of a Pikachu that
for some reason is able to understand
everything Tim says and he can
understand what Pikachu is saying so
they embark on a mystery to discover
what happened to Tim's father and figure
out why Pikachu and him can understand
each other when my wife and I left for
the screening I looked at her and I said
are you ready to go see a Pokemon film
just like the strangeness of saying that
the fact that we are now in 2019 at a
point where there's a live-action
Pokemon movie and we've had ghost in the
shell and Alita battle angel and all
this craziness
now Pokemon to me has always been more
of an anime because I was never as
interested in the games as some people I
know that technically this is actually a
video game move even though Pokemon is
just as famous as an anime as well as a
card game it's a gigantic media
conglomerate thing Pokemon is it's been
huge ever since I was a little kid on
the school bus and people were fighting
over pokemon cards like they were $100
bills
I like this franchise I have a soft spot
for it but I've never been a die-hard
fan you know what I mean like last year
I did go to see the power of us in
theaters just for fun I didn't even
review it I just watched it purely for
fun like I was excited to see this movie
and I was really hoping that it wouldn't
be awful thank God it's not awful this
is an entertaining film and that's
really all I wanted out of it because
the source material it ain't Shakespeare
for me Pokemon was never about a story
filled with depth and nuanced emotion
it's just Pokemon like they're cool
little things and you can collect them
and it's fun and and the major themes of
Pokemon was hope and believing in
yourself and little kids can watch it
and be entertained by it and also learn
valuable lessons across every episode it
was never meant to be this incredible
story and so I was just hoping the film
would be entertaining it it was
the best part easily of this movie is
Ryan Reynolds as Pikachu he provides all
of the best humor as Pikachu the
character is also the most entertaining
in the film whenever you see it fight
the things that Pikachu does in the
movie really really cool stuff I mean
it's kind of what I wanted to see and
rhyme city felt lived in it felt like a
place I love the idea of Pokemon and
humans interacting in this place and
working together you saw squirtle
putting out fires and just you could see
like the practical application of every
Pokemon in the city so they did their
best to try to make it make some sense
as well the movie also tugs at the
heartstrings fairly successfully in a
few places where I didn't expect to be
wrapped up in the story the action
sequences whenever Pokemon are battling
or anything else is going on that
involve Pokemon doing cool a lot of
fun Rob Letterman directed this he also
made the first goosebumps movie so he's
now had two properties from the 90s he's
been able to adapt to the big screen and
he's done a fairly consistent job with
both of them I can't really complain I
played a lot of the 3ds game I didn't
play the whole thing there are certain
parts of this film that are similar to
the game some choices that are made in
the movie in regards to the order in
which things happen that's also similar
to the game and I like that they were at
least attempting to sort of wink to the
fans of the game you can tell that the
people behind the movie actually did
kind of give a about the fan base
and didn't just want to cash in on the
fan base like some previous adaptations
of things Dragonball Evolution you can
really tell that they actually gave a
and they tried to make a movie that
the fans could enjoy still this is by no
means a flawless movie if you really
want to get nitpicky about the Pokemon
film which I'm going to it's really
stupid the human characters suck all of
them I did not care about a single one
of them in fact there were times when I
look at the main character played by
Justice Smith and I went get over it
dude
just get over yourself man you are a wet
blanket you are annoying and boring you
need to stop being this way and it's not
entirely justice Smith the actor it's
it's the way the characters written
because Pokemon to me was always this
very hopeful
experience where you can just relax and
watch it and have a good time but the
first 20 minutes of this movie are
legitimately sad and actually more
beyond that really it's kind of
depressing because it's not just about
the fact that this kid doesn't know
where his dad is or thinks maybe his dad
could be dead he kind of doesn't care
and so I get that that's part of his arc
you're supposed to show a character in
one place and have it and in another
place totally get that it's just that a
large majority of this movie our lead
character doesn't give a which kind
of makes us not give a you know
what I mean he starts caring a little
more when he runs into an intern for a
news company played by Kathryn Newton
and she's interested in this story of
this missing detective and he obviously
thinks oh she's kind of cute and so now
all of a sudden he wants to be on this
mission and Pikachu's over there like
and there's a lot of humor there which
easily saves the whole movie whenever it
goes back to the human characters though
I'm like geez these guys are
underwritten and I just don't care the
Pokemon are the stars of this movie by
far and to be honest that's kind of what
Pokemon is about you don't necessarily
watch the show because you really love
Ash Ketchum you play the games and you
watch the show because you want to see
the new Pokemon and you want to see them
battle I mean Pokemon Stadium was like
the back in the day and that was
another issue I had with the movie there
wasn't enough Pokemon battles I would
have loved more of that there wasn't a
lot of catching Pokemon either there was
really just one scene actually besides
that it's it's a very different film
from what you might expect if you are a
fan of Pokemon it's more so an
investigation movie but when they do
find information for their case it's
sort of just thrown on them by these
expositional holograms that tell stories
and it just felt so easy like it didn't
really feel like they were uncovering
anything so in summary the human
characters are flat and boring but the
movie was entertaining and consistently
funny because of Ryan Reynolds as
Pikachu
he saved the entire film and gratefully
there's a lot of him and they seem to
understand the core of what Pokemon is
about
and they're able to communicate that as
best as they can in this movie it's
about as good as a live-action Pokemon
film could be although if they do make
more I would like them to focus more on
people hunting for pokémon battling with
Pokemon tournaments things like that I'm
gonna give Pokemon detective Pikachu a
b-minus well guys if you see Pokemon
detective Pikachu this weekend let me
know what you thought of it don't expect
much out of it it's about as good as it
could be it's funny and they did a
pretty good job with recreating Pokemon
for the big screen at least it doesn't
look like this guy's thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]